[Music]  while j-law just got hitched Lady Gaga  is newly single she was at a friend's  bachelorette party this weekend and  posted and about to be married woman and  me a single lady confirming her  three-month romance with audio engineer  dan Horton has ended the news comes just  two days after Gaga's devastating fall  off the stage  how's the recovery she showed us when  they have to x-ray almost your entire  body just dance gonna be okay just last  night Gaga was on stage at her Vegas  residency and we know how mother monster  bounced back in addition to our ice  baths hot baths and compression suits  Gaga stays limber with this pretty  tricked-out gyro tonic machine that  kinda looks more like a torture device  want one for your living room well  that'll set you back $6,700  [Music]  [Applause]